spoiler alert potential venom to plot
leaked Morbius helps carnage escape
spider-man cameo I'm very curious to see
if any of this is real movie comes out
so far from now honestly I've had things
leaked for me that have really upset me
for getting leaked and then I watch the
movie and so much time as fast as I
completely forget about the leak and I
have a feeling that's probably what's
gonna happen today if any of this is
true a year and a few months from now I
own that speculation until it all blurs
together and honestly if Morbius is in
this movie it's probably gonna be in the
venom trailer how's it going everybody
it's Warren welcome back to my channel
the cosmic wonder where we talk about
all things relating to Marvel and today
we have a true Gotham plot ladies now
there's been a lot of changes that
happen to venom two recently we got an
official title for the film a very tiny
teaser for the film and the release date
has a brain have been pushed back but
luckily for us we actually do have quite
a bit of information about the film many
dentists leaks including the scars of
videos and over the past couple of days
I've gotten a lot of questions about a
certain venom to plot leak that connects
venom two with Morbius and spider-man
and I have to say this is by far the
best plot leak that I've heard so far
and if it ends up being legitimate venom
two is going to be is not saying it's a
hundred percent legitimate okay let's
dive into it and be sure to subscribe
when notifications turned on so you can
stay up to date on everything related to
Marvel and venom two and the 550,000
winner has been chosen you can check out
a video I guess in two days since we
covered exhaustion wonder videos so did
not catch the official title reveal for
venom two it is venom
let there be carnage people seem to have
mixed feelings about this title but it
does suit the movie well a lot of people
would have rather it have been called
maximum carnage like the comic series
was but keep in mind it's not the exact
same storyline so they're not gonna call
it the same thing but I bet you if Kevin
Feige was a hundred percent in charge of
choosing the title he would have called
it maximum carnage but today's plot
leaked a lot of people have been asking
me about and it is truly great now if
you are trying to avoid any and all
spoilers for venom two and
I suggest you click away now if you're
with me this leak is a compliation of
different league and definition Co
dynasty still it's still only any of
videos on some of these leaks in the
past but we're tying them all together
in this video and they make a lot of
sense now although this isn't titled
maximum carnage and although it's not
going to be the exact same story as
maximum carnage it is going to have a
lot of similarities for example the very
beginning of the movie is reportedly
going to start off just as the beginning
of maximum carnage started off but with
a little twist
according to a report from insider
Daniel RPK serial killer Cletus Kasady
will be imprisoned in the facility
awaiting execution for his crimes this
facility is the very familiar asylum for
the criminally insane
the Ravencroft Institute this was teased
in the post credit scene of venom one
now the Ravencroft Institute in the
comics is in New York but they have
moved that from New York to California
for venom two now here's where things
get very very interesting and tie into
Morbius and possibly the sinister six
according to a Morbius plot leaked in
the film it's rumored that Morbius is
going to go to jail and it's there where
he comes face to face with the vulture
and scorpion in prison Morbius
definitely in jail I read up Morbius B
didn't call a prison riot and then to
escape and during this vulture and
scorpion escape as well at some point
vulture with that he's forming a team
and asked if he wants to get involved
now this is most likely the scene that
they showed us in the Morbius trailer
where vulture is talking to Morbius
vulture is wearing a prison uniform and
Morbius as walking down the alleyway and
vulture definitely knows who he is so it
is safe to assume that vulture and
Morbius definitely have met before and
considering the fact that vulture is
still wearing his prison uniform it is
likely that this leak is accurate that
they met each other in prison and then
both escaped but here's the kicker and
the tie in this which says that when
Morbius causes the prison riot and
vulture Morbius and scorpion escape
Cletus Kasady
also escapes that's right according to
this leak Cletus Kasady is going to be
in the same prison as vulture scorpion
and Morbius now this is awesome news but
doesn't come as that big of a surprise
because we know that all of these movies
venom venom to Morbius and upcoming
spider-verse films are going to link
together because Sony does have their
own spider-verse so the fact that
they're crossing over is definitely
awesome but is expected now
shriek has been confirmed for the movie
as well and it has been confirmed that
she is going to be played by Naomi
Harris and just like in maximum carnage
shriek is in the prison with Cletus
Kasady and manages to escape with him
and follows him now here's where things
get very interesting email and crazy
Cletus is going to escape from the
prison and Eddie Brock is going to hunt
him down but during this time Cletus
Kasady somehow gets infected with the
carnage symbiote which is a spawn of
venom we then learn that riot is still
alive and carnage and riot end up
connecting with each other and they help
infect shriek now this is going to be a
little bit different from the comics
because in the comics shriek doesn't
actually wear a single about nip you
late sound now in maximum carnage she
breaks out of the prison with Cletus
Kasady and then she follows carnage on a
killing spree along their path of their
killing spree carnage and shrink end up
gaining a lot of followers who would
like to kill as well and they all end up
looking at carnage and shriek as their
mother and father
well that appears to be happening in
venom let there be carnage as well the
League goes on to say that Cassidy's
insanity begins to infect the carnage
symbiote and it slowly becomes just as
twisted as he is riot ends up alerting
the other symbiotes on his home planet
that there are people on earth to feed
upon they arrive on earth but due to
carnage now being corrupted it becomes
cannibalistic and he begins to attack
the other symbiotes and feed upon what
we will see when the symbiote reached
earth and venom to carnage will absorb
them all and become stronger because of
it and we will get the giant carnage
from the comics however carnage doesn't
absorb riot or shriek and instead he
plays it cool and pretends to be their
ally waited until the right moment to
absorb them he becomes their leader and
together they all team up against venom
now according to this new leak this is
apparently where venom slash Eddie Brock
is going to reach out to spider-man
slash Peter Parker now think about
pretty good reporter at that he probably
has kept up with the events of
spider-man two actually Peter Parker and
spider-man far from home Eddie Brock
knows that spider-man is Peter Parker
Eddie Brock with his reporter skills is
probably somewhat of a good detective as
well so if he wanted to find spider-man
he probably could and he's going to do
and that's all this league says but we
did have another league a couple of
months ago that said that spider-man was
going to be in the end of venom two in
the final battle venom is about kill
Cletus Kasady not carnage but Cletus
Kasady but spider-man stops him and this
is apparently where venom is going to
turn on spider-man and this will start
their long lasting feud and apparently
could somehow in the future set up a
spider-man vs. venom film but that's a
long shot
however spider-man appearing in venom is
not a long shot and is actually pretty
probable about a week ago Tom Hardy
posted a picture to his Instagram of
venom eating spider-man
he basically bit him in half but he
deleted the photo about a minute after
it was out now this isn't uncommon for
Tom Hardy to do especially when it comes
to venom two he's actually posted and
deleted photos pretty much instantly a
few times when it comes to venom two
however just a few days ago when we got
the venom two official title and teaser
he did it again so he posted and deleted
what if he's saying that and then you
have to consider the fact that Sony
wanted Tom Hollands spider-man to appear
in the first venom film however Marvel
said no they didn't want people to
confuse the Marvel Cinematic Universe
with the spider verse that Sony has
however it looks like spider-man just
spider-man and all of the spider-man
characters in the MCU are going to bleed
over into Sony spider-verse and the
thing about Tom Hardy posting and then
deleting photos is that they've actually
all meant something in the past Tom
Hardy once posted a photo of a very
crucial location in teased what to
expect in the film in the photo you
could see a crest that said st. Estes
orphans which also read home for
unwanted children in the comics written
for boys and where the serial killer got
the taste for murder in the comics he
would go on to push a girl who rejected
him in front of a bus and would
eventually burn down the orphanage and
that's really what this photo looks like
it looks like the orphanage
run down and in ruins and according to
this leak that is apparently what Eddie
Brock is going to be investigating in
the film after Brock does some serious
investigation work he will uncovered
that 12 deaths were caused by Cletus
Kasady remember gang post-credit scene
of the first venom film where Eddie
Brock is talking to Cletus Kasady in the
prison Eddie Brock learned some
information that leads him to the
orphanage and after exposing his victims
Cassady will hunt him down in order to
stop the news getting out there's gonna
be carnage so this is apparently why
Cletus Kasady is going to want to hunt
down and kill Eddie Brock in venom let
there be carnage so of course not only
are we going to be seeing venom versus
carnage but we're actually really going
to be getting a Cletus Kasady versus
Eddie Brock as well
now unfortunately as I mentioned in the
beginning the sound oh the fly has been
pushed berries now what's really
interesting is that Morbius was
originally scheduled to be released on
July 31st of 2020 however this movie got
pushed back as well and is now coming
out on the March 18th of 2021 this keeps
it ahead of venom so if this leak is
true and Morbius vulture and scorpion
are the ones that help Cletus Kasady
break out of prison this all still lines
up which means that it could very well
be true and would be the perfect way to
tie the movies together and it also
means that the sinister six is coming
but let me know what you think just not
with the majority of the members you
would probably want to and of course all
things Marvel for live updates on news
you can follow me on Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching well family out
okay so granted the sources that Warren
is pulling from in this video are some
sources especially like Daniel RPK who
has reported on sort of things that have
actually come true in the past we always
that take this with a grain of salt that
being said let's roll with it is that
this is real now before we roll with it
I also want to say I feel like 50% of
this spider-man stuff is not going to
happen in the movie
I don't see them using spider-man that
heavily infused in the plot before
spider-man three comes out I could still
see a cameo I could still see a
post-credits T and I could still see
something being that integral like Oh
carnage is on the loose he's got this
like cult going we need to stop him he
sees a giant carnage now and then he met
him hunts down spider-man and I need
your help I just don't see that
happening I mean if they do find
whatever I don't buy it the Peter would
be across the frickin country yeah it
would have to leave their leg it would
take way too much time I shout the last
place that Peter Parker's gonna do is go
oh I need to leave the biggest city in
the world I'm gonna go to California
none of the other biggest city I mean
sure venom could travel fast and
everything but I feel like it's a little
too much but there's other things that
based off of like certain photos the
fact that they're calling this let there
be carnage I could see a lot of this
actually playing out all that stuff with
Morbius breaking out of prison and
countering vulture and you look at the
trailer it just seems like that's a
really high possibility I think it would
be pretty cool though if in Morbius they
do have that breakout scene maybe you do
see like Cletus Kasady in the background
or he has like a brief moment but you
don't really see him break out and then
in venom 2 you do the perspective of the
breakout from cletus's perspective I
think that would be a really neat way to
tie in your like cinematic universe
would be yeah that way it's like okay
more be it's only focuses on vulture and
scorpion which by the way I hope Michael
mando does get a chance to do his
scorpion portrayal truly if you've seen
his work on better a call Saul you're
gonna be missing out on something very
special both Sony and Marvel if you
don't utilize Michael nando's talents a
scorpion do you see that breakout and
then you go into venom to where you see
it from like oh but actually this was
also happening I think that'd be a fun
little nugget to infuse and all this
stuff would shriek it's making me kind
of flash to Woody Harrelson days of like
Natural Born Killers because they sound
like a bunch of crazy Psychopaths
they're lovers and then they start
gaining a popular following along the
way that sounds really cool
it's really making me wish this movie
was r-rated well the hopeful aspect of
having the carnage it's funny and this
is like the bigger bulkier version of
the argument we had the first time which
is like Venom's but pretty r-rated
character and then you look at carnage
and you're like carnage is about being
over yeah it is about violence and grit
and gore and nastiness it does make me
wonder about how they're gonna handle
the hats that edge at least I've seen a
lot of pg-13 movies lately be able to at
least encroach upon the intensity level
even if they're not showing the literal
carnage so you know here's hoping I
guess but I really like the idea and it
kind of goes to something I've been
thinking of which is a it's a really bad
idea as per all these comic-book
properties to keep all your high-powered
villains in one place just seems like a
poor arc you just feel like you should
have special cells all over the world
and then just hide them one place at a
time but I think that could be a cool
way to do it because the villains are
obviously the rotating door of these
hero worlds and so if you had the actual
Ravencroft Institute you know or in DC
or Arkham Asylum be this kind of
crossroads for all your villains where
you do see other people and you do
interact with them they do kind of
inhabit the world but yeah you can show
from multiple angles and so you know
that will kind of allow for a crossover
that isn't so lurid and in-your-face
yeah especially because they've been
trying the sinister six for so long and
the approaches to that have varied as
well and as for spider-man I can see him
showing up to halt venom from killing
Cletus like that actually seems like it
could be a neat moment because it
presents an ideological divide that
allows you to keep venom as your
antihero maybe you know and spider-man
is your hero hero highly doubt he's just
gonna be like I'm here for act 3 yeah
you know I mean that'd be the same usage
that they kind of use them for in civil
war to a certain extent yeah the idea
that you have serial killer a couple
potentially burning down an orphanage
like with venom one I could see how they
got away with it like you minimize the
blood at the end of day it's venom
versus riot so you can you don't have to
be all crazy violent about it but when
you're setting up Cletus Kasady
especially before he gets infected with
the symbiote he's already doing some
pretty sadistic things I think you need
a little bit of an r-rated edge but you
know we'll see they're definitely not
going to do it even I like it
hate them both solidly and also enough
to make it so that when Cletus is
infecting carnage which i think is a
really cool concept that reads as
believable - like we have to believe
that his villainy and evilness and
deranged that of carnage or maybe even
usurps it and I think if there is some
of that cultish element to it really
giving rise to Cletus Kasady in here I
like the idea of calling it let there be
carnage even more before that sounded
like kind of fun and a bit of a tagline
title to slap on there but when you say
let there be carnage I especially going
off of the last line there's gonna be
carnage and now you're saying let there
be carnage as if he is he's not just
he's not just a bad guy killing people
now he's an influencer yeah into chaos
and mayhem I think the title actually
sounds a lot more sinister with that
layer of context yeah guys you gotta
take it all with a grain of salt as of
now I mean this all sounds cool but
venom there's certain movies work I'm a
little bit more lenient on Adam I'm
reading up on some possible leaks you
know there's other films like I wouldn't
watch the Black Widow one that's a
pretty cool so you're like yeah I'm like
I saw the first venom movie that was
really fun riot
I really can't it all seems like there's
just trying to set up a bunch of stuff
it's probably a lot of cheesy fun I'm
not too dismayed by the idea of getting
some stuff themselves as a franchise
with some level of gravitas I think just
speculation is fun yeah and also we
won't be getting a real trailer for a
while or they actual movie for a while
so might as well dive into some of this
stuff until the pandemic has really
slowed down and guys subscribe to cosmic
Wonder subscribe to the real rejects a
dunce already what do you think about
the idea of this being the actual way
the movie unfolds and are they doing way
too much
does it sound cool to you want to be
r-rated last but not least
Roza para how you doing beautiful the
lady Stark of our channel Rosa part I'm
so proud of you a she has a really hard
job she works at a hospital especially
during this time where it's really
dangerous she's seen a lot of things up
close and personal she's still staying
healthy still doing a job that I would
never dare to do but this time thank you
so much for being brave and for being a
strong supportive mother as well and on
top of all that she is part of the HCA
now which is the Hollywood Critics
Association and she is launching her
baby she's throwing one of her children
to the sky it's a really you're gonna
want to see them really suggest a guy
that she's redoing man
and were you super chat the higher fan
she's launching her podcast in june
latin x lens this is a major major
passion project of hers film acerbic is
one of her biggest passions in the world
and she is going full force with it and
it's already making strides further than
so many people I know
so Rosa para bet your ass going to be
supporting that podcast have us on if
you'd like I would love to be on it be
safe out there say hi to your children
for us and take care these children for
me